on april 30th people here in sweden and
in neighboring countries like germany
finland denmark and estonia celebrate an
annual feast day known locally as vol
boris mesoafton or more often called by
the shorter name vol bori it is a day
that is celebrated in different ways
across different regions but it's
generally a communal event where people
gather to light big bonfires sing songs
and hold speeches to announce the
arrival of summer and for students at
various universities as is usually the
case a chance to get very very drunk
but what are the origins of this feast
why do we celebrate it and what's up
with the bonfires
volbois messofton translates as the eve
of walpurgis's mass and is often called
simply alpergus knight in english the
tradition dates back to medieval times
in germany from where it's spread to
neighboring countries including here in
sweden as is often the case with
traditions here it originates in
catholicism and with an eighth century
english missionary called saint walpurga
while program from which the swedish
name vol bali derives was a prominent
christian figure at the time who came to
germany as a missionary with the aim of
converting the local population to
christianity she appears to have been
quite successful at this and pretty
shortly after her death around the year
777 she was canonized as a saint on may
the first 870. and this is actually the
origin of this feast day it is a
celebration of the canonization of saint
valporga on may the 1st the celebration
on april 30th called the eve of saint
paul progress's mass is as the name
suggests a celebration of the eve before
may 1st much like christmas eve or
easter eve as it is known over here and
since the middle ages this day has been
celebrated across northern europe it has
direct origins in religious history and
in the catholic church but walborg is
also a lot more than this
it just so happens to fall on an
important non-religious day as well the
last day of april has been considered a
transitionary point where winter turns
to spring and summer
it is often on may 1st that the cows and
other cattle are released and allowed to
graze outside again for the first time
during the year
in sweden and in the general
consciousness of most regular people who
partake in the celebrations this
connection to the arrival of spring is a
lot more apparent and important than a
relatively obscure christian saint that
most people don't know about anyway
volboy is quite a popular feast day that
many people participate in in different
ways there are some recurring features
of this day which everyone knows about
and does but as is often the case when
it comes to religious rituals and
traditions people don't always really
know why they are doing any of those
rituals on well perguso's night the
swedes will gather outside to socialize
usually the local government or
inhabitants have arranged activities
like food musical performances and
generally to promote a feeling of
community
music plays an important role as choirs
will often perform traditional songs in
celebration of the arrival of spring
it's also common that a local celebrity
or politician holds a speech on the same
subject volvo has become an especially
important holiday for the students in
the country barbara celebrations at
various universities like that in
uppsala can be very intricate and
complex involving various steps and
stages like marches
choir singing picnics champagne
breakfasts and in general the
consumption of large amounts of alcohol
celebrations usually take place in a
relatively open field and the most
important and common feature of volboy
is the lighting of a big
bonfire
the origins and reasons behind this
bonfire isn't entirely known and various
theories are often put forth saint
valperga herself became strongly
associated with protection against evil
spirits and witches some traditions
claim that on april 30th because of this
transition between winter and spring and
summer witches and evil spirits are more
active and the most common explanation
for the bonfire is that it has the
purpose of warding away these malignant
forces others argue that it is related
to the arrival of spring and the
releasing of cattle to outside
environments as a result of this the
farmers would light bonfires to ward off
predators that could easily prey on the
newly released cattle in any case the
reason behind the fires and all of the
other rituals aren't really that
important this is a good example to show
the nature of how religious traditions
and rituals generally work people don't
always care why they do things but only
care about their very doing itself
most swedes don't light the bonfire and
celebrate volboy because they want to
remember saint walpurga and her powers
to ward off evil forces they do it
because everyone does it they do it
because their parents did it because
it's just something we do
religion and rituals is first and
foremost something that we do as many
scholars of religion today argue the
action or performing of a ritual itself
is what always comes first it's the
priority any rationalization about why a
ritual was performed comes secondarily
if at all it is through ritual actions
and ritualization that we create
meanings that we create social bonds and
identities and that is at least
according to one interpretation what
religion and ritual is all about and any
sort of metaphysical or cosmological
meaning behind any ritual in that sense
is really
secondary rituals like that on
walborough's mesoafton are performed not
because of some underlying theological
or existential purpose or reason but
because they bring a sense of
familiarity and comfort it creates a
sense of social belonging and cohesion
being a communal festivity in which a
large amount of people participate it's
not about saint walpurga or really about
the arrival of spring and summer but
about us and how we interact and create
bonds and connections to other people
and a larger social context
and i think all this can give us a few
things to think about when it comes to
traditions what their functions are and
how we relate to them
gladwaldboy and i'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign